hallo freunde max und ich hatten uns
gedacht hey was können wir heute denn so
heißt es machen wir wollten kartfahren
gehen wir wollten ein schwimmbad
eventuell dies machen das machen
letztendlich sind wir den baumarkt
gefahren haben uns denken scheiß gekauft
und wollten uns eine art auto bauen
jedenfalls haben wir da recht viel
gefilmt ich hoffe ich kann das ganze
jetzt noch ganz gut zusammen schneiden
und ihr seht es jetzt einfach mal als
ihr euch fragt wie soll ich den ganzen
scheiß im automobilen deine des maut ist
einfach so eine fusion aus matt und lud
tsunamis genannten dachten wir wir
wollen das mobil
glaube ich und wir wollen jetzt das
motto wir bauen das heißt wir wollen
jetzt irgend wann und wie beispielsweise
kappen oder handschuhe oder irgendeinen
anderen krampf und bauen das
letztendlich irgendwie der garage
zusammen und zwar das mobil des maut
setzt zusammen aus matt und loops und
sounds und auch wenn mir die nächste
reise machen immer ein hashtag maus
irgendwas twitter irgendwas machen und
er macht das bei mir irgendwie zum
anstoßen wollen wir sind bisher weiß
dass wir uns so komische heilige geholt
haben von den hertha- hier verdient uns
gleich haben die performance einer
holzplatte tun und da so holden
runterzuschrauben damit wir schon mal so
dass grund mobil hand und dann kommen
die ganzen schnickschnack sachen wie es
ist zeit so letztlich so was halt alles
also das was jeder halt quasi auf dem
mars mobil drauf hat etwas gefunden aber
wir brauchen dafür einen handkarren und
den wohlig jetzt geben wir mit unseren
ein tolles können wir das ist alles
mitkriegen inzwischen stand jetzt gerade
ich zeig euch das ganze mal wir haben
hier das hier werden wir in der mitte
durchschneiden dann haben wir hier so
was zum anlehnen und schrauben wir dann
hier drauf auf unserem untergrund und
kommt hier in die ecken hatte ich mir
gedacht diese stange die reine hin und
da unter zwischen gespannt wird dann
dieses material wird am ortsrand drauf
sprechers habe ich mag's von werkzeug
das wir mitnehmen was es so kurz
schaumstoff den packen wir überall
außenrum falls wir irgendwo anecken und
jetzt der letzte einkäufe tätigen sind
noch rollen weil die bei seinem auto
quasi nicht dass das sich jedes rad
dreht wenn das hier ist quasi steady und
das hier vorne da man variieren
ich wäre halt mehr dafür dass wir mehr
geld ausgeben als minister qualitativ
hochwertig sein okay dann haben wir
jetzt hier mit den letzten einkauf
getätigt
ganz zu schrauben ist hier angebracht es
läuft doch alles also ich will damit
auch grad schon ein bisschen herum
geküsst worden wie hier die teile noch
von der weiteren schrauben dann kommt
daraus warum dieses ding
damit es auch schwimmend gern wären die
rollen sind natürlich darunter wie ich
das fenster gezeigt hat und hier haben
jetzt auch den sitz den haben wir hier
mit fünf schrauben selbst gemacht wir
müssen vielleicht oben auf ihn mit
käßmann dass wir nicht drum wackelt weil
wir uns halt gedacht wir machen nur
einen sitz drauf von der verlagerung her
damit sich einer vielleicht hinten raus
stellen kann und hier kommt jetzt gleich
noch die flagge dran damit die
sicherheit an züge an und damit jetzt an
haben haben
freunde das ist nicht wahr wir haben die
ersten test abgeschlossen so freunde des
gibt es jetzt vorbei ist wahrscheinlich
jetzt ganze szene und alles gesehen vor
dem haus mobil max und ich waren grad
noch schön interessen so als kleine
belohnung bösen date wird ein youtube in
denn es war also quasi unser kompletter
tag während morgen echt gefragt das
können wir euch machen oder haben uns
gedacht kommen wir waren bauwerk
castings und bauen
irgendwann sind wir auf das mobil
gekommen sollten erst kartfahren und
natürlich frage geht warum machen wir
das
wir wollen erst kart fahren hat man
gesehen ok 60 minuten kart fahren musst
du 45 euro wir haben jetzt insgesamt
bezahlt für das mal zu probieren
ich kann zwei dinge der irgendwie sowas
um den dreh aber wir haben 90 euro
bisher noch nie so viel spaß macht das
mobil ist einfach viel schneller
hartmann kannst also mache ich weiß
nicht welche machst du den hat aber
angst dass mit vielen eine frau
schneller durch bitten
also wir hatten altana gopro ist ein
thermometer dran und das war natürlich
schon 470 noch mal da waren wir schon an
die 300 schnell
also das war schon recht schnell egal
jetzt abschließende worte wenn es euch
gefallen hat so ein wieder bewegende
scheiß machen oder so weil das hat uns
einfach mega viel spaß gemacht
dann würde ich mich über eine bewertung
freuen der markt auch ganz viel gefilmt
den findet ihr oben oder beschreibung
verlinkt und sonst was das von diesem
kurz wie lang ich hoffe es war sich ganz
zu krank und welche sagen die
verabschiede mich von euch von diesem
bild hiervon wachsen